hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts the effects of
epigenetic therapies on the tumor and
host immune system
presented by Katherine Chiaki nalli she
is an assistant professor of
microbiology immunology and Tropical
Medicine at the George Washington
University
I am Marjorie Torres of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
libraries labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom or center of your
screen or use the ask the question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the
accreditation button located in the
promotional board at the bottom or
center of and follow the process to
obtain your credits please join me in
welcoming dr. Katherine Sheridan le I
will now turn the presentation over to
her hello today we will speak about
research that my group and others have
done on the effects of epigenetic
therapies on the tumor and host immune
system so I will do a brief background
on epigenetics in general and then
discuss tumor immunology as well as on
exploration of the intersection between
these two areas so the first thing I
want to go over is you know what is
epigenetics in general this is a cover
of Time magazine from maybe almost ten
years ago now where they did a pretty
good job explaining um as they say why
your DNA isn't your destiny and
genetics comes from the Greek Epis above
genetics basically it is a study of how
DNA is packaged and then how genes are
expressed so on the next slide you see
the chromosomes in the nucleus here so
this is the DNA packaged into
chromosomes and the way that it is
packaged and that this negatively
charged DNA is wound around positively
charged proteins called histones so
these are these little cylinders you see
and this graphic shows some
modifications to these histones where
they say h3k9 etc on or DNA methylation
which they show in these little red
circles each of these modifications to
the way DNA is packaged affects its
expression affects which genes are
expressed so I'll first introduce
eukaryotic DNA methylation this is what
my laboratory studies and what we showed
has a very big impact on the interaction
between the tumor and the immune system
on and these patterns are generally
erased and very early development
pre-implantation and established in
early development they're maintained
throughout the remainder of development
and there are different enzymes that add
DNA methylation so on when you have
unmethylated DNA strands on the left of
this on the slide the DNA
methyltransferase that we call de novo
which dnmt3a or 3b will add methylation
that's the little red sorry a little
yellow circle and then a maintenance
methyl transferase will maintain this
it's a different enzyme dnmt1
and this is a stable mark on the DNA in
the next slide we see why this is
important so you can see here that these
methylated nucleotides so on the little
yellow circle on the CPGs that
methylation brings in binding proteins
called methyl cytosine binding proteins
M ect one or two they come in and it can
also recruit other proteins such as
histone deacetylases to create a more
compact chromatin structure histone
deacetylases
remove acetyl groups from histones and
remember that acetyl groups are
negatively charged so that when they are
on histones they actually push away the
DNA
getting a more active chromatin
structure and thus enzymes that remove
them will make a more compact chromosome
structure the end result of DNA
methylation and HTX all of this together
is to create a more compact chromosome
structure and repress transcription so
when you have DNA methylation when you
have h stacks you have less
transcription of RNA from these sites so
in the context of cancer we've actually
been treating cancers epigenetic drugs
for the past 15 to 20 years and the
original rationale here was as you can
see in this slide that while tumor
suppressors genes can be mutated in
cancers they can also be silenced by
epigenetic modifications and so on the
left here you can see that here's our
tumor suppressor gene it has DNA
methylation to silence it but it also
has histone modifications these are
these big red hexagons we can treat
these tumors with dnmt inhibitors and I
will label these in my talk as visa or
DAC they're these eyes editing or v is a
2d oxy sided diene and these are both
actually used in the clinic now on to
treat my lattice plastic syndrome and
sometimes AML leukemia and these both
removed in a methylation we then can
also use drugs that inhibit hbox once
again so getting rid of these
suppressive modifications to help turn
this tumor suppressor gene back on so
this was the original rationale for
treating kids with epigenetic drugs to
reverse silencing of tumor suppressors
because epigenetic silencing unlike
mutations is actually reversible and the
next slide shows an example of a trial
this was published in 2009 almost 10
years old in leukemia where they're
comparing a two-sided diene in blue with
chemotherapy in yellow and you can see
that the survival is significantly
better with a decided een this was
really the first success of epidemic
drugs in this case in blood cancers and
in my postdoctoral lab before I joined
there have been some really great
studies showing that actually treating
solid tumors instead of blood tumors
with epigenetic drugs could have
important effects on the tumor biology
so um they showed that on this is to
valence group they showed that while
high doses of these dnmt inhibitors Aiza
and Zack cost cytotoxicity which will
kill tumor cells and not really affect
these tumor initiating cells but can be
toxic to the bone marrow low doses
really causes DNA demethylation gene
reactivation and growth inhibition and
tumor cells as well as epigenetic
reprogramming of these initiating cells
it is well tolerated by the bone marrow
so the concept of using the low dose TMT
inhibitors kind of reprogram solid tumor
cells that was first described about um
six years ago and we have a treatment
paradigm shown here on where we treat
with low dose two here 500 animal or a
society dean for about three days and
then we actually rushed the cells for
seven days we did this on a group of a
very large group of cancer cell lines
including breast kits or colon cancer
lung cancer and ovarian cancer and we
harvested the cells to figure out what
were the pathways that were activated so
we analyzed the DNA methylation
expression and protein we also assessed
homogenous City by transplanting into
mice so we were trying to explain we
didn't really know what caused the on
the limitations on the tumor cells by
these drugs we're trying to figure that
out by pathway analysis so we analyzed
the RNA that was increased on and we did
this using gene set enrichment analysis
these are pie graphs showing the up
regulated gene sets by gene set
enrichment analysis in three cancer
types we look at the common ones you can
see on the left here that this immune
part of the pie is quite big for the
upregulated gene sets and that is only
one in the dell regulated gene sets we
were surprised by this because this is
treating cancer cells cell lines growing
in a dish and there's there's no immune
cells in there so this is immune
signaling coming from the cancer cell
and you can see for the four different
tumor types here on there's a high
percentage of immune gene sets the
highest actually was an ovarian cancer
and we went on to really validate these
findings mechanistically and ovarian
cancer
so it turns out that this immune
signaling is driven by the interferon
response in the tumor cells and the
interferon response is our cells kind of
primitive immune response so an
epithelial cell when it has things like
a viral double strand RNA or bacterial
RNA or bacterial surface proteins has
kind of sensors in the cytoplasm so
these are some double strand RNA sensors
as the TLRs as well they can bind to
these foreign species activate IRF
signaling which can cause up regulation
of cytokines and chemokines as well as
transcription of interferon beta this is
the type 1 interferon response this is
been secreted it binds to its receptor
on a either a neighboring cell or the
same cell and through status signaling
causes up regulation of interference
immolated genes importantly sad
signaling is also crucial for regulation
of PDL 1 which is the immune suppressive
like in and I'll revisit this later when
we go to the mouse experiments looking
at the interaction between the tumor and
the host so on these is DSR involved in
apoptosis when you have a viral
infection you might want to kill the
cell destroy the viral RNA or help with
antigen presentation to host immune
cells that would be coming in to get rid
of the cells target the cells have the
virus and importantly we see this up
regulated across the board so um so here
you can see that um the all different
cancer types so breast cancer is in red
colon cancer is in blue and averman
cancer is in green
I like this infinite for in signaling
across the pathway importantly we also
see an increase in engine processing and
presentation so here on the right you
can see the fold changes for these
different image and processing and
presentation molecules in breast cancer
in red cell line colon cancer and blue
ovarian cancer in green and on the Left
we have a schematic of the pathway so
for antigen processing and presentation
you have antigens including male mage my
use the one there's many more antigens
and we note that these are also
regulated they're processed by the
proteasome and then tap one on the ER go
to the golgi and then are presented by
this MH
class 1 molecule looks kinda like a
cloverleaf and we also see that
upregulated often this is downstream of
the interferon response um
so on the right you can do the fold
change in the different cell lines in
addition we show in yellow the d.ko a
cell line and this is an important line
because this is the colon cancer cell
line that lacks the DNA
methyltransferases
so here we're comparing this really
knockout to the control the parental
cell line is saying is a genetic
knockout of emts similar to the ease of
treatment um so these are is our drug um
it's a signal from our drug an actual
effect of DMT inhibition or is enough
target effect because we see the same
phenomenon with a genetic knockout we
assume it's actually an on target effect
um and others and also showing this um
in previous work so I'm going to show on
right now there's a trial going on for
nie so one targeting in ovarian cancer
so this was a phase 1 trial on and they
also see that the in empty inhibition up
regulated antigen processing and
presentation and actually the n way so
one edge and was increased they combined
decided beam with anyway so investing in
human ovarian cancer and saw some
exciting responses in terms of C's
t-cell responses down where you saw one
the tumors so we were very curious about
patients on epigenetic litical trials
being run at Hopkins while we were there
to see if these show mu enough
regulation as well and these were trials
with patients who have breast and colon
cancer treated with DMT inhibitor AIDS
acidity in a stack inhibitor ms 275 or
10 estat and we do see that the therapy
up regulates immune signaling and
patient samples so on the graph I'm
showing you here is interfering response
genes and they're all across the x-axis
there's really two ready to show their
names but we are looking at the post
versus pre treatment of these patients
we see an increase in interferon
response leads to patients as well as an
increased engine processing and
presentation genes although this is not
as dramatic but in general we do see
that the patients resemble the felons um
treated with these epigenetic drugs and
our colleagues also published an
important paper showing the same
response in nonce
the lung cancer interestingly um they
had an opportunity where the patients
being treated with epidemic therapy for
non-small-cell lung cancer the ones that
progress there were five that progress
on epigenetic therapy they were actually
given the choice to go into a trial a
different trial of anti TB one immune
checkpoint blockade therapy the patients
that went on to this are shown in this
plot here so we're looking at the change
in target lesion from baseline so three
of these five patients showed great
responses for years two of them
progressed but these high patients did
significantly better than um the rest of
the patients had not been pretreated
with epigenetic therapy on which let us
ask the question whether perhaps this
epigenetic therapy and these immune
pathways could sensitize to Demian
therapy and right now larger trials
going on at Hopkins with the combination
of epigenetic and immune therapy in lung
cancer and so we'll be able to test this
in a larger cohort so what I've shown
you thus far as we see that epigenetic
therapy up regulates immune signaling
cancer cell lines and patient samples
but this may sensitized immune
checkpoint therapy and this is not a new
discovery so this is published in the
90s that when you inhibit the inital
transferases we do see stat increases on
that one and two transcriptions um in
colon cancer but we really curious out
what the mechanism was to figure that
out for how this is happening so first
of all I wanted to point out that these
interference generated genes that were
upregulated they did not lose
methylation at their promoter region
that's how we would expect any gene
increased by gain of T inhibitors to be
increased but this was not the case on
so we first block this path wait a bunch
of different points so when we block the
interferon beta interaction with its
receptor shown by this red cross we see
a decrease in signal so on the graph on
the right here in this take new cell
line we're looking at three enter
friends tonight of genes I fi 27 I 5 44
L&I fi 6 in blue is the MOC and then red
is the AIDS of treated and you can see
that and then the darker on the darker
red bars arching with
is blocking antibody you can see that
it's dose dependent but this blocking
antibody rescues the increase in their
different stimulated genes which meant
that the pathway was activated upstream
of this we get rid of maths which is a
sensor which is a adapter protein
helping out the md5 and rig-i sensors
that sense double strand RNA and tail r3
we also see an effect on this response
showing that double strand RNA
sentencing is important and only
inhibits tat signaling we also get rid
of the response showing it's really a
canonical interfere and pathway
activation and there were other clues
that it was an RNA response so we
actually um isolated nucleic acids from
cells both untreated and treated with
Asia and transfection to recipient cells
to see what was activating this response
um and here you can see that there are
many different sensors for different um
nucleic acid species in the cytoplasm so
we were trying to figure out what those
from DNA effector an RNA effect we
isolate in transaction to recipient
cells we're looking at the ada over
month full change here the DNA do not
have an effect but the cytosol like RNA
as well as the poly a fraction of this
increased interferon beta and neza
samples the non poly an RNA was not as
impressive so it looks like a poly a RNA
response and we were then very curious
about what the source of this um double
strand RNA could be some of these are
double strand RNA sensors um and we went
to look at you know parts of the genome
that have been called junk DNA so non
cloning DNA is more than 80% of both the
human and mouse genomes as we know about
one to three percent of our genome codes
for protein an interestingly ninety
percent of our DNA methylation is in
this non-coding DNA we focused on a
group of this called endogenous
retroviruses that I'll refer to as herbs
and these um integrate Endora genome a
long time ago and are methylated in
silence to maintain genome stability so
these viruses now are not able to form
viral particles and in fact but at the
time it was kind of like an HIV
infection where the cell wants to
methylate it silenced it and make sure
it's not integrating it anywhere else in
the genome so these herbs are about
8% of our genomes we can see on the next
slide we're looking at transpose well
elements in total and 45% line and fine
elements are there and the yellow
section here is ours about 8% of the
genome so there have been previous data
on on the non-coding RNAs and so this
next slide shows a PNAS paper from good
cops group on show MIT p53 cooperates
with DNA methylation and norfair and
responds to maintain epigenetic
silencing or repeat the non-coding RNAs
and the takeaway here is that if you
look at this graph from their paper when
you have p53 null cells treated with um
decided being a DMT inhibitor we see an
increase in these same you know Pharaon
genes that we saw in our work and that
this was actually when they sequenced
RNA is from these cells there were a lot
of herbs there were a lot of signs and
satellite DNA so they proposed a model
where all three transcripts are
regulated by both pp3 suppression and
DNA methylation and that demethylation
of these causes too much double-stranded
RNA and activation of the interfere
response its Rd to really confirm this
we have hot besides the azo removes
methylation herbs producing viral RNA
and triggering the interferon response
and we collaborated with an excellent
group in Germany with Pam streusel and
writer strick at the University of our
lung and to show this there are experts
and they had qrt-pcr assays for all
these herbs so this graph here has
different herbs on the x-axis about 20
or so and then we're looking at time
course here so of different days at a
the treatment and when bars are colored
in that meant that there's a significant
difference between Ada and mock as we
see in general a big half regulations
are on day seven so four days after we
finish days at treatment and below you
can see this is just we added up the
whole or molecules in the cytoplasm
pretty in a group of RNA so really we
have pathi size that's not one specific
of causing this response but rather an
accumulation of double strand RNA you
can see for two of these cell lines
specifically age 27 80 and tecnu there
stated it getting creases in the a the
comparison lock
importantly we also showed confirm that
these are controlled by DNA methylation
that had been described very well in the
literature
we wanted to make sure we spin our model
here we're just comparing two herbs and
sc2 and herbs I'm one between this
double knockout cell line locking the
dnmt is parental sign HTT one with six
so here we see that both are increases
the RNA level and then using methylation
specific PCR we show a decrease in
methylation so here you myselfi convert
DNA and design crime myself a conversion
changes unmethylated sees to tease and
methylated sees remains these and then
you design specific primers for the mess
lemurs unmethylated on DNA so here you
can see this this herb has ample
identified both at chromosome 11 and 7
the water is clean for both nest site
unmethylated the positive control is
methylated 4 and then the 8200 6 all
methylated nothing in the unmethylated
the d.ko lacking Munim T's loses
methylation and then mock compare Daisy
there's more unmethylated so we do see a
loss of methylation right now we're
doing genome-wide studies to confirm
this on at many low low side importantly
we overexpress the earth without
epigenetic treatment we also see an
interferon response so this is on each
bar here is a different over expression
so blue is the end of you to ERV red is
the Erb 3 and greenness inside one we
compared this to over expressing control
vectors including GFP and grey and ER in
black and on the x-axis are the
different interferon genes so we're
staying the same at a fair response we
overexpress these so Irv's alone can
cause this response so to summarize in
Figure adapted from Jonathan licked on
here are the endogenous retroviral genes
they have both a 5 carbon 3 times ltr'
which really act as promoters for these
normally there are methylated as you can
see here and they have these methyl cpg
binding proteins there's not
transcription DNA methylation inhibitors
remove the methylation
activate transcription this double
strand RNA binds to sensors and causes
on your fear response and we get
activation of the inter ferrous ponce
immune activation and decrease
proliferation so after showing this this
is really confined to the tumor cell we
were very curious as
to really learn how can this affect
cancer patients in the whole patient can
it activate a recruit host immune cells
so I wanted to go through this really
nice um review article by Bob Stryver
ask mice and old in 2011 on the role of
immune cells and immune tolerance in
cancer progression so I'm just to first
to press over one can understand what's
going on the term microenvironment and
then we can talk about how that pathetic
drugs affect this um so in the top here
you can see that here's your normal
tissue on when these normal cells are
hit by things carcinogens radiation
chronic inflammation inherited mutations
you can develop um transform cells and
these are these or in cells left here
they release danger signals they present
tumor antigens and they have ligands for
natural killer cells um so the immune
system so this is a they're going to
elimination the immune system as you can
see here is all over this so cd8 t-cells
natural killer cells these all can come
in recognize the tumor cells NK cells
will directly kill tumor cells based on
the ligands they present the cd8 T cells
will kill them based on images they
present they secrete cytokines here as
you see by the arrow and suppress the
tumor however a lot of tumors will come
to equilibrium so the tumor cells you
can see are become more poorly amino
genic and immune evasive
so there's um these cells are going to
start presenting molecules um like GDL
one you can have on T zones of a study
that has ctla4 that will prevent this
immune surveillance and causing you to
escape
so in this escape graphic the immune
cells have been able to evade the host
immune system there can be other
suppressive signaling like il-6
tgf-beta i do for macrophages so
depending on the cells in the tumor
microenvironment on you can then have
immune escape by the tumor often as a
result of mutations that the tumors have
gone through to upregulate
ligands like PDL one or get rid of
interferon singlet
so in general we'll do we're dealing
with the problem of immune escape on and
how can we reverse this in tumors and
then they
you check my blockades including anti
ctla4 and anti PDL one have been able to
stop partisan escape and be able to
target the cd8 t-cells to kill the
tumors again so cancer main therapy as I
mentioned it was the breakthrough of the
year for science in 2013 and we've known
for a long time this is an ovarian
cancer that t-cells are very important
so this is overall survival and the
orange our patients that have high
injection world t-cells upon surgery the
black is liquor that has low and
obviously that once they have t-cells
are tumors do a lot better so this is
not a surprise um and we actually took
our upregulated viral defense change
with asa
and still has to feel the good cluster
ovarian cancer tumor from TCGA to see if
um they were perhaps more main reactive
so this heat map is if you look on the
right there's um this list of these
Azoff regulated interferon genes
starting with DDX 58 ending with ISU 20
so every column in this heat map is a
different patient and the blue is low
expression of this gene set the red is
high expression you can see a low
cluster on the left
hi Custer in the middle and kind of a
medium cluster on the right the bars
above this that say TCGA subtypes are
the different subtypes that's defined by
um TCGA and so right is immune reactive
pink it's collaborative yellow is
differentiated in blue is excellent the
immune reactive subtype has a higher
prognosis and is associated with higher
expression these interferon genes the
proliferative has a lower prognosis and
is associated with low expression of
these so generally seem to go with this
immune reactive subtype another
important question is in primary tumors
we were curious about whether high and
low herbs correlated with interferon
response levels so this is just in 20
ovarian cancer tumors and left and right
here these are the ones with lower
expression on the left and high on the
right and this is a heat map once again
looking at the expression level the
interference stimulated genes where blue
is low and red is high you can see that
the interference related genes are much
higher in the higher of levels so we
predict that baseline levels of hours
will actually determine interferon
expression so to combine it to the me
checkpoint blockade for cancer I mention
before but basically anti pd-1 works at
disrupting the interaction between the
PD one protein on t cells and the PDL
one ligand presented by tumors on in
general this role this interaction will
inhibit T cell signaling and elimination
of tumor cells if you disrupt this
interaction you allow T cell signaling
and elimination on index CPI for is a
bit more complicated ctla-4 is a lie you
know the mebut or e t cells that works
through MHC on so antigen presenting
cells on to Tibbett effector T cells
what's inhibiting 6i4 breaks this
interaction and activates effector T
cells against the tumor so we're very
curious about what how can we combine
these two therapies we know is that I
mean checkpoint blockade produces
durable long lasting responses in solid
tumors including melanoma lung cancer
and kidney cancer but I would like to
point out that the majority of patients
not respond to me in therapy alone this
is um approaching fifty to sixty percent
in melanoma but in other solid tumor
that's about twenty percent so we have
eighty percent of patients that are
really not benefiting from this the data
in terms of why they respond right now
point to the new antigen load or the
amount of mutated proteins and mutated
peptides present for the T cells to
recognize as well as whether or not
there are T cells in the tumor and so
our goal release to use epigenetic
therapy to increase immune signaling and
tumor cells to recruit and activate host
cells and sensitize to in therapy we
believe that the interfere in response
initiated by epigenetic therapy will
help sure recruit and activate host
immune cells and we first tested this in
a trial in melanoma with our colleagues
at sloan-kettering and these were
melanoma patients treated with anti
ctla-4 so this heat map on the left on
each column as a patient the red bar
right below the patient numbers
indicates good response the blue bar in
the case no no responder and the heat
map below shows levels of the
interference stimulated genes and once
again these are not tree with epigenetic
ferrites just immune therapy but the
blue are the low level of these genes
and they correlate with no benefit
the red have high levels these genes and
correlate with long-term benefit and
this is also quantified in the graph on
the right here so we do see that this
predicts melanoma response to fic today
for perhaps because it's recruited
immune cells that tumor um we then load
them in a mouse models we could sense
types to immune therapy so here we're
looking at the tumor surface over time
um and a little bit busy but the you can
see that the bars on the top are the
untreated or just ada alone and then the
orange circle is just anti CCA for just
immune therapy and then the four lines
in the bottom are mean therapy plus a
bunch of different doses of Aiza and you
can see that that's significantly better
so thus far we've explored on the fact
that GMT inhibitors can hibbett
methylation activator expression cause
an interference three double strand RNA
sensing interferin signaling kenderson
pop ptosis actually serve treatment of
host immune cells on and we were curious
about whether other academic drugs could
also activate this response so here I'm
going to talk about both CMT inhibitors
as well as on to a stack inhibitors
called ITF 2 3 5 7 and MSU 75 and these
inhibit the class 1 HDX
in general on they're going to affect
histone acetyltransferase an increase at
the viral defense response so this graph
on the x-axis for looking at different
viral defense response genes and then
the y-axis we're looking at the h ii
hibbott are alone in blue we don't see
much of a response at the RNA level
haze' and red there's an increase purple
the combination we actually do see an
increase
adding aged acne better jeiza this is
mimicked by the herbs and so here you
can see that a two different herbs is
increases these in red but the
combination of h deck inhibitor with a
said purple isn't is increased over AIDS
alone while h deck inhibitors alone have
no effect here on the armory minimal
effect so the combination does seem to
increase of transcription and right now
we're doing a genome-wide study to
really look at this beyond the effect on
just yours
so we can add to our queue model that
age deck inhibitors add a scintillation
at um the herbs and in addition duties
removing methylation to increase its
response the last piece the puzzle to
put together here is how does effect
activation recruitment of hosts immune
self and we tested this in an immune
confident model of ovarian cancer where
you have what are called Mo's cells
Mouse ovarian service epithelium that
were derived from the surface epithelium
of Mouse ovaries and spontaneous eye
transformed and now as a spell on you
can grow these are Syngenta con Black
Sticks mice and you inject them into the
peritoneal cavity where they form on
nodules but also two more ascites that
is very similar to these studies that
human ovarian cancer patients experience
so on that this is a pretty good model
of ovarian cancer in a mouse and
importantly is in a new confident models
you can studied interaction the host
immune system with the tumor cells so
here if you look at our schematic de 0
to 42 we treat with all training Aiza
and age deck inhibitor and resilience
and then we added anti PD one
seeds we could sensitized immune therapy
here traditionally ovarian cancers are
pretty resistant to immune therapy we
drained ascites from these mice to
analyze the volume for the tumor and we
also analyzed see immune parameters
it looks again we're using anti pd-1
this is detailed below to release
t-cells against tumor cells to act to
activate them to kill the tumor cells so
one of the most important thing was to
make sure that the mouse system was
similar to the human and that we do see
enough regulation of these viral defense
genes by Aiza so here on the y axis
we're looking at the fold expression and
these are all defense genes and the
x-axis shows you the different genes
would you see an increase of these in
the mouse just like the human that the
on mechanism seems very similar and the
first thing we noticed as we see
increased t-cell infiltration
i'm going to show you several graphs
here that have a lot of bars in them i'm
and i'll walk you through right now um
in general we're going to go so so white
here is moth gray as anti PT one blue is
msu 75 a histone deacetylase inhibitor
and then the dark blue adding PvE 151
light green is IPS an HD inhibitor and
then dark green bad anti pd12 that Aiza
is in red adding a TP one of that isn't
pink MSD 75 is in purple and the dark
purples with FFP d1 AZ plus ITF is in
orange and darker orange adding PD and
how could you want to that so um we see
here and this is just looking at the
percentage of city 3 cells in the tumor
microenvironment
is that compared to the mock in white
all of the aides of groups that are
starting with the red bar and ending
with the orange bar are significantly
increased so it is really causing more
t-cell and filtration we apophysitis to
the interfere response on the next slide
we see that there's more to infect
ourselves so these are BC interferring
game positive cells these are quite low
baseline it's a very immune suppressed
to your micro environment but if you
look on the three bars on the far right
of our graph here the combination of a
za plus h ii Heba plus anti PD one
significantly increases these and this
could be due to the H stack and Hitler's
effect on the host immune cells
themselves an activator for Agana
we also see an increase in T helper
cells or interferon gamma cells a cd4
cells that are interfering gamma
positive but similarly the the three
bars all the way to the right
significantly increase this the
combination of two epigenetic therapy
plus anti PD one increases these the
most and we see a similar trial with
natural killer cells so this is looking
at activate natural killer cells NK
cells Express interferon gamma
these are increased with a's alone if we
go from kind of zero to five percent but
increased higher about 10% or so in the
combination epigenetic therapies so once
again the combination is better than a
cell alone plus anti pd-1 importantly we
see a reduction of suppressive myeloid
cells these are called milo derive
suppressor cells and in general these
are cells that inhibit the effects of
cytotoxic t cells when you look at this
mock bar in white we see that everything
else is decreased compared to it so most
epigenetic therapies actually decrease
these and this been a lot of work
previously published that a second
hitter's decreases in general this is
not new lastly we see a reduction over
macrophages with any of the AIDS of
treatment groups so once again we're
looking at mock in way up here and then
all the A's are treated in the the six
bars to the right and with the red bar
ending with the orange bar we see a
decrease here on we are currently
figuring out whether this m1 or m2
macrophages we did not differentiate
between those two in these experiments
and importantly we see an increased
interference signaling and immune cells
so this is looking at the interfere
response again the x-axis these inter
fair response genes and cells we sorted
out from these experiments of blue with
cd8 t-cells oranges cd4 t-cells and then
um the grey c11 B or myeloid cells and
we do see increase interference
signaling here which could be helping
that response so both in tumor cells and
immune cells we do see interference in
line so the next time really just slows
show the summary of the immune micro
environment where um on the Left panel
amok M month tumor microenvironment is
quite immune suppressants with lots of
macrophages in blue MDS sees in red few
t-cells and green and few NK cells in
purple when we treat with AIDS ad
there's fewer macrophages in blue fewer
MDS sees more t-cells in green but the
combination with age deck inhibitors
really the most potent um where you have
interfering gamma expressing t-cells
note K cells and the tumor burden really
reflects this immune activation where so
here we're looking at the middle of a
Eddie's and these mice to measure tumor
burden and you can see here that um the
the graph on the left is looking at all
the samples and then we're just blowing
up the a the treated group the graph on
the right where the is it has a dramatic
effect but the combination of aiza
ITF and anti PD one has the most
significant effect on tumor burden
Mindy's mice to the combination which
has the most beneficial immune effects
also has the biggest effect on to memory
and we also see that survival mimics
this this is looking at survival curves
on and the orange curves compared to the
duct to the black curve is the triple
combination versus the mock we do see an
increase in survival we're currently
doing experiments where we continue to
treat with epidemic therapy
pd-1 says stopping at IPD one right and
we hope to see bigger increases in
survival this is not a huge increase in
general mimics the immune activation the
trimmer Bernie and I wanted to point out
that we're not the only ones do needs
experiments Michael Goldberg's group had
a really nice paper where they showed
Truman with decided beam increases
lymphocyte migration function synergizes
was teaching for blockade in a different
model of ovarian cancer and when things
do go to Michigan showed that um
epidemic drugs including gene of T
inhibitors as well as easy to -
inhibitors on can reactivate chemokines
including CXC all nine and ten from
tumors help bring an inactivated host
immune cells in recent work from um
defend young bloods group at st. Jude's
showed that DMT inhibitors can actually
read they call rejuvenate T cells so
that DNA methylation of genes and T
cells are important for t-cell function
um can be reversed by DT inhibitors and
also reactivate um immune cells and once
again synergize well with PT one
blockade so there's now really a quorum
of reports showing the epigenetic
therapy specifically need of T and
butters concerned eyes very well with um
with P one blockade as well as other
read their appease so the last question
we wanted to ask was in the interfere
response crucial to this no one else has
really answered this and once again
we're using the Sam you competent mouse
model driven with Asia as well as anti F
nor one which you can see below and the
red X blocks is type one interferon
signalling from the tumor and we see
here so this is showing three graphs on
the first is total new cells
second is T effector cells and the third
is activated natural killer cells so
let's look at the total immune cell cd45
from cells per mil if we're looking at
the total cell number I mean cell number
there's not a difference we mock and
anti fr1 but if you look at math isn't
aiza
there's a significant increase but this
is blocked by adding anti-us or one so
when you block the interfere response
there's no more immune cell increase on
the total number of T effector cells is
quite increased with a the compared amok
but this increases
gone when you inhibit the interfering
response and the activate and K cells
once again increased when you're
compared easy to mock but then that's
gone when you block the interfere
response so we conclude the interfere
response is necessary for this increased
immune effective ASA and the ascites
burden mimics this we're here we're
looking at Hayes Byrne mock compared and
- r1 is very similar haze' is quite
decreased for this red bar compared to
black but when you add anti affair one
block interfering response all of that
data set is gone and the survival on the
right here mimics this so um data for
response is necessary for this aja
immune effect
so in summary and I've really shown you
that on both H deck inhibitors and um T
inhibitors can activate curves as well
as other double strand RNA molecules
that we have not yet catalogued that can
act to make double strand RNA sensing
proteins on triggering interferon
signalling cancer cell apoptosis and
activation the recruitment of host
immune cells I've also shown you that
this can sensitize community on I cite
the papers below if you want to do
further reading on this um and our next
steps now and actually our ongoing or
clinical trials in both non small cell
lung cancer and high-grade serous
ovarian cancer combining DMT inhibitors
in some case also H stack inhibitors in
anti PD one so we're going to test to
see whether it's turned patients what we
observed in cancer cell lines as well as
mouse models of cancer and see if we can
really make the patients that are quite
resistant immune therapy sensitive to
mean therapy through increasing I mean
signaling from their own tumor cells and
I just like to acknowledge everyone that
contributed to the work here I'm so in
my lab as well as collaborators at the
University of our longan sloan-kettering
my postdoc lab at Johns Hopkins
including Steve valence and azano
jus cradle on Bob Shriver at Wash U for
reagents on the anti of star one
antibody um as well my funding from NCI
f/32 and candy nine I'm happy to take
any questions thank you for your
attention thank you dr. Tripp and Nellie
for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is do
baseline levels of erv RNA change tumor
immune microenvironment so from what
we've seen thus far there does seem to
be a correlation between baseline levels
of ERV RNA expression and activation of
the interferon response in primary over
in cancer tumors and so we just show
this in a cohort of about 20 we're going
to expand this to a larger number of
ovarian cancer tumors and hopefully also
look at other tumor types but we do
predict that this will hold up I think
we do more studies on it in general
thank you for that answer our next
question is do every genetic therapies
effect ERV levels in normal tissues in
addition to tumors in question because
we are always looking for cancer
therapies that will affect the cancer
cell and not the normal cell um so first
of all just think about how the MT
inhibitors work um DMT inhibitors only
are active during S phase because
maintenance DNA methylation is added
during S phase so it's they're only
going to affect dividing cells which
will probably be more cancer cells but
we should also think about off target
effects in cancer cell types such as the
dividing got epithelial cells
um so currently my lab is working in our
mouse models to see whether we see
activation of Indian singer kind of
autoimmunity in normal tissues and we're
not seeing anything on anything that
look that approaches the level in tumor
cells yet but we really need to figure
that out still I think it's a really
important question thank you it looks
like we have time for one more question
our last question is do other epigenetic
modifiers affect the tumor immune
microenvironment so I mentioned in this
talk DMT inhibitors as well as H deck
inhibitors um there's been some really
good work
on easy h2 inhibitors and how those also
can activate cytokines and chemokines
coming from immune cell um we don't know
as much about other modifiers though one
thing I would be interested in I know
other groups are working on this as well
is looking at h3k9 methyl transferases
so this is a repressive histone
modification in general that will
repress herb expression perhaps
modifiers of those could also increase
our expression and I know some groups
that are working on that so hopefully
we'll get an answer to that soon and I
would predict that that would also show
immune modulation because the double
strand RNA and interfering response I
would like to once again thank dr.
Katherine chip and Ally for her
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2018 you will receive an
email from Lavery's line you know when
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
video colleagues who may have missed
today's vlog bet that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye